hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of Raiders of
the story have I talked about Batman the
Animated Series yes okay a few times
well then you can gather that it was a
huge hint so with all that popularity it
only made sense for the makers of the
show to move on to the next logical
superhero yes Howard the Duck they took
their entire creative team and they went
into Howard thanks Superman
unlike the Batman cartoon though they
did just start out in the middle of the
story here they had to go straight to
the beginning of his origin and give him
you guessed it a story arc but this
would be tricky seeing how most people
already knew the story arc of Superman
Moses with aliens so it would be a
little bit more difficult to make this
fresh and new
does it succeed well let's take a look
so we get our first episode the last Son
of Krypton yeah last one until we see
the guest our list of future episodes we
get a look at Superman's father jor-el
who was very happy that his science suit
is able to hold all of his chips
gathering readings for final
subterranean probe gets attacked by a
Metroid monster but manages to fight it
off and continue with his research
research that a giant computer named
Brainiac is very interested in knowing
the planetary council demands that I
analyze your data
people don't like to be spied upon I'm
sorry Tyrell this cartoon series is too
important for me to allow you to
jeopardize so we see that Krypton is a
little bit more diverse than it is in
the other movies not only do they have
black people on Krypton but also British
people too real British not that fake
British that Brando was trying to pull
off he'll stop going over the data
I keep thinking what if it supports your
theory what then
we can deal with it this is Laura
Gerald's wife and of course his son Kola
which begs the question is the last name
in this family ill they go back home to
look over the data they've discovered
Valera's father played by Tony Jay it's
not enthusiastic and tries winning his
daughter over to his side if he persists
in predicting the end of the world it'll
be the end all right of his political
and professional career but what if his
right father
try convincing the council he has won
support of his theory
you
why is that so then because you can
never be wrong jor-el
I never let my ego get in the way of the
facts well let me let you in dude they
have dogs on Krypton how is it the
evolution of this planet is almost
exactly the same as Earth's it creates
creatures that looks like Flying
Spaghetti Monster mucus and yet it still
somehow produces human beings and dogs
how does that work I don't know maybe
God made them so Jareau goes to the
council and pleads his case
leaves no doubt that the planets core is
undergoing a mounting chain reaction
that will eventually destroy Krypton
Lotus as Brainiac yes nice outfits there
guys today's wardrobe is brought to you
by the letter M as I've stated before
the temblors are the result of a slight
polar shift he's wrong he doesn't know
he was built to monitor all of Krypton
and as I might head served us far better
than upstart scientist with apocalyptic
visions yeah come on don't you know it's
the job of conservative news programs to
tell you it's the end of the world act
now and we can save everyone and how do
you propose to do that
put everyone in the Phantom Zone
on another planet
but nobody believes his story and jor-el
is stuck trying to find answers only to
discover that Brainiac has been lying
the whole time you're transmitting your
memory to a satellite saving yourself am
I not the repository of all Kryptonian
knowledge if the council knew Krypton
was doomed they would frantically put me
to work on calculating an evacuation
plan a futile gesture given the time
remaining wait a minute jor-el built a
ship and they both must have known for
the same amount of time that the planet
was doomed why could he come up with an
evacuation plan hell jor-el had a plan
ready to go why didn't Brainiac just say
bitches you're screwed
piled into Gerald's car it's a six
seater but the guards locate him and try
to shoot him down
[Music]
I would say that this scene is ripping
off Judge Dredd but that would imply
that somebody actually saw Judge Dredd
[Music]
so he escapes the guards and makes it
home where the family decides the only
logical choice is to save their only son
[Music]
Lara I could send you with him there's a
risk but if I have time to recalibrate
the course no my love I'm staying with
you I much rather risk my baby boy being
sent into a dangerous world with no
adult they'll leave your side my lone
farewell
so Brainiac takes off as does color and
the planet meets its timely demise
you know it just hit me I don't think
they ever specifically say in this
version what it is that destroys them is
it the inside of the planet is a
colliding with another planet is the Sun
too close is it Marvin the Martian again
oh I'm going to blow up Krypton it
obstructs my view of Venus in that
lovely hmm as we begin part 2 we see
kal-el crash lands on earth right in
front of a couple known as the kids Oh
Martha what are you doing
would put a baby in a spaceship that's
just my point could be Russian a Sputnik
baby I don't care what he came from all
I know is he needs us Jonathan look how
he's reaching out to you ah yes the hell
of calling authorities we'll just
replace the word kidnapping with
adoption and all our problems will be
solved what do you think of the name
Christopher what do you think of Clark
so Karl has now grown up into a teenage
Clark Kent but he can't help a feel he
doesn't quite fit in Lily I'm feeling
kind of weird
you've always been weird if you ask me
hey it's Lana you know the girl who's
had a crush on you since we were three
you can tell me wait what you know the
girl who's had a crush on you since we
were three okay anyone who would just
awkwardly say that they are the weird
ones I think the only thing weirder is
that Clark doesn't take a robot I mean
you're a teenage boy I don't care what
planet you've come from your hormones
would grab that Mary Jane wants some in
a millisecond and I could see things too
like in the gym the Stevenson's inside
putting up decorations for the dance
you're saying you can see through walls
so how many times have you peeked into
the girls locker room Lana so he brings
up these issues to his mom and dad and
they decide it's finally time to tell
him the truth
they show him the ship as well as a
strange device that came with it
hello son you've activated the message
we placed in your escape rocket we are
your parents no no it can't be true you
are the sole survivor of Krypton a
planet similar to earth in many ways
this was oh sorry son
advertisements you may have already
discovered that you are much stronger
and faster than a normal human being it
will give you abilities that no other
human has you may also notice your voice
getting deeper sporadic hair growth and
people's inability to recognize you if
you wear glasses I'm not a freak not
[Music]
at least you can do is not run like a
complete pussy your freak but he
discovers more of his powers and figures
out that being a freak is well freakin
awesome
Oh
okay
and faster than you can say will
transition he suddenly grown up into a
man and saving people in Metropolis just
ask little Danitra Evans I was fully
grown the window when I lost my balance
of Phil suddenly this big blue angel
with red wings came down and caught me
this is where they found in E truck and
that's where she fell from 30 floors up
clearly Dimitra is possessed by the
devil by your torches and pitchforks
here this deals the front page of The
Daily Planet from Lois Lane
voiced by Dana Delany and she's pissed
because despite her wearing a skirt
about his why this toilet paper she's
not getting the attention she feels she
deserves some sprouty new-age
granola-crunching fluff piece on angels
good timing Lois I want you to be the
first to know I'm hiring a new guy on
the city desk
is he cute you tell me oh of course if a
woman says that about coworker it's fine
but if a man says that about a co-worker
suddenly it's a sexual harassment suit
that I listen to once the Amanda so Lois
is teamed up with Clark Kent and they go
to cover the latest weapon demonstration
from Lex Luthor
yes like in most comic book universes
we're always looking to make you safer
with the most psychotically designed
death machines the world has ever shit
their pants looking at
I'd like to say that i view the lexo
suit not as an instrument of war but as
an instrument to end war look out for
[Music]
oh god no stop daya mention on the
villain I don't need to I
[Music]
all right you get one but I never want
to see you in trouble again
got it I'm gonna hold you to that so the
villains tried to destroy another plane
to get Superman away from them as this
begins our third part of the story arc
[Music]
well wait a minute no wonder the plane
went down so easily half the equipment
isn't there everyone always wants to fly
Southwest but then when you see where
they cut corners of course he saves the
plane and a mime thank God and all of
Metropolis is amazed where did he come
from what does he want look who I'm
asking
nice yes I know I heard it too here's a
clip of something awesome to offset it
better okay so everybody wants the story
on Superman and Clark is wondering
what's the best route to take suddenly
people are calling me Superman they want
to know everything about me some are
even afraid of me you'll always be Clark
Kent Superman just helps out now and
then still it wouldn't be bad if people
knew a little more about Superman I
don't want anyone thinking you're like
that nut in Gotham City
you know spider something so Superman
decides to give the story to Lois in a
not so subtle way excuse me miss lane I
believe I'm the one you want to talk to
where are you just hang on
[Music]
it's okay I've learned this by watching
my parents we just call this an adoption
instead of kidnapping and everything
will be fine as far as I've been able to
piece together I'm the last survivor of
a planet called Krypton Krypton uh-huh
all I ask is that you tell the truth
about me and that is I'm not here to
scare anyone and if they ever make a
movie about my life don't hand it to the
guy who directed 300 I saw sucker punch
it was bad so whose prints this story
and people get the info they've been
looking for but there's still the issue
of Lex's missing suit which Clark now
thinks might have been planned so that
the Pentagon would pay even more money
for Lex to make an even larger one when
all is said and done this could net you
a multibillion-dollar windfall you're
very amusing mr. Kent is it nice work
Smallville you're only the second person
I've ever seen get under Lex's skin
who's the first me when I dumped him
whoa
ancient history anyway what makes you
think no no no you go back to dating Lex
Luthor tell me everything give me all
the details you can let me know he's
ball down there right so Lois goes to do
even more research aboard one of
Luthor's ships she gets talking with one
of the heads of the ship played by
Malcolm McDowell you must know there's a
trade embargo between the u.s. and
kaznia
we're part of a diplomatic envoy trying
to restore friendly relations I'd be
more than happy to answer any questions
that you might have
oh damn it Frank could you open that
door any wider I can think of some
doozies I'll bet it's okay we'll just
say it's an adoption so they tired to a
pole and get ready to exer off we're
clear loser tickets you'll never guess
what's gonna happen here I guess the S
on his shirt stands for Speedy Gonzales
under
hey your bra might also be missing just
ignore that
[Music]
oh yeah they got that angle because it
was so important to the story no really
I swear they got that angle because
cinematically it just works so much
better it was much more compelling I
mean what are the reason what they
possibly you can't even hear me anymore
can you
yeah well let's try this so long
sweetheart
[Music]
nevermind me just a giant walking
mechanical robot going for stro piece of
shit I'll stab you in the llamo
[Music]
so it looks like this fight is over and
back on going to the psalm but Superman
does get back up and puts that evil
machine in his place
ah ha so Superman saves the day but
there's still no evidence leading
directly back to Luthor but that doesn't
stop old sue from paying him a visit
you see Superman I own metropolis my
technology built it my will keeps it
going and nearly 2/3 of its people work
for me whether they know it or not even
you have to admit it's a model of
efficiency he knows he's evil
why don't you float on in and we'll
discuss it
say something I'll be watching you
Luthor
though art designs may vary our voices
might change and we may even work in a
few swear words every now and again I'll
be watching you for a long time so
Superman flies off into the night and
everybody Cheers
Vee and what the fuck what's with the
walking clearances
brain systems activated
[Music]
well I'm sure he's just going to
enlighten people of the Kryptonian
culture in a peaceful manner so that's
the Superman animated series story arc
how does it hold up well for a story
that most people already know it's a
pretty good reinterpretation it feels a
little rushed at times which is weird do
you think being a TV show they could
have as many episodes as they wanted to
explain it but you know what it still
holds up but best parts are in the first
episode as you really do feel the dread
and despair that's sweeping over our
main characters but the other stuff is
good too Superman is good Lois is good
Luthor is good it's a decent beginning
to a decent show you ever get a chance
check it out so because I reviewed
something positive this week I'm sure
you want me to review something negative
next week well okay what's one of the
movies that you guys ask me over and
over to review
[Music]
why around petrified
nice s